>>> IN OUR NATIONAL LEAD, THE
U.S. NAVY TAKING EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES IN RESPONSE TO A VERY
TROUBLING SERIES OF DEATHS,
INCLUDING THREE SUICIDES IN THE
SPACE OF ONE WEEK, AND AT LEAST
FOUR SUICIDES TOTAL AMONG THE
CREW OF THE AIRCRAFT CARRIER
"USS GEORGE WASHINGTON."
CNN'S PENTAGON CORRESPONDENT
OREN LIEBERMAN WENT TO VIRGINIA
WHERE MORE THAN 200 CREW MEMBERS
ARE BEING ALLOWED TO MOVE OFF
THE SHIP AND SOME ARE DESCRIBING
JUST HORRIBLE CONDITIONS ABOARD
IT.
>> Reporter: FOR NEARLY FIVE
YEARS, THE "USS GEORGE
WASHINGTON" HAS BEEN HERE AT THE
NEWS PORT NEWS SHIPYARD.
THE SHIP NEEDS FIXING IN MORE
WAYS THAN ONE.
CURRENT AND FORMER CREW MEMBERS
WHO SPOKE WITH CNN SAY THE
NUCLEAR POWERED AIRCRAFT CARRIER
WAS NEVER READY FOR SAILORS, AND
THE ENVIRONMENT ON BOARD WAS
UNLIVABLE.
THESE IMAGES FROM THE SHIP
PROVIDED TO CNN SHOW THE
CONDITIONS ON BOARD.
THESE VIDEOS OF BROKEN WASHING
MACHINE FLOODING COMPARTMENTS, A
BATHROOM IN DISREPAIR.
CNN WAS UNABLE TO BOARD, BUT
SAILORS SAY THIS WAS THE NORM.
ONE SAILOR WHO WANTED TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS TOLD US ABOUT POWER
OUTAGES, AND THE FOOD --
>> THEY JUST RUN OUT OF FOOD.
IF THEY HAD ANYTHING LEFT, IF
YOU'RE LUCKY, IT WOULD BE A
CEREAL THING OR ONE LITTLE
CHICKEN LEG THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE UNDERCOOKED.
>> WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU TRIED
TO FLAG THESE ISSUES WITH YOUR
SUPERIORS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> Reporter: ON FACEBOOK, FORMER
SAILOR JACOB GRELA SAID HE WAS
SO HAPPY WHEN HE FOUND OUT HE
WAS ASIGNED TO THE CARRIER.
BUT SOON HE SAYS, WEEKEND TRIPS
HOME BECAME AN ESCAPE.
WITH A YEAR LEFT ON THE SHIP, HE
TRIED TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT
WITH THE SHIP PSYCHOLOGIST, ONLY
TO FIND OUT IT WAS A SIX-MONTH
WAIT.
>> I TRIED TO TELL MY LEADERSHIP
THIS IS -- THIS COULD BE A
REASON WHY THESE DEATHS ARE
OCCURRING.
>> WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> I WAS MET WITH THE SAME
NEGATIVE FEEDBACK.
>> Reporter: THE NAVY SAYS SEVEN
SAILORS ON THE SHIP HAVE DIED,
AT LEAST FOUR BY SUICIDE.
SAILORS SAY THE NAVY BROUMT IN
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES AFTER
THREE OCCURRED IN ONE WEEK IN
APRIL.
ONE SAILOR WHO DIED BY SUICIDE
WAS XAVIER SANDER, WHO WAS JUST
A YEAR OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
HIS FATHER SAYS HE WILL ALWAYS
BE THE FAMILY HERO.
>> HE LOVED HIS JOB, HE DID HIS
12-HOUR SHIFTS, AND HOW DO YOU
SLEEP ON AN AIRCRAFT CARRIER
WITH JACKHAMMERING AND SMOKE AND
SMELLS DURING THE DAY?
SO HE WOULD SLEEP IN HIS CAR.
IT'S JUST AWFUL.
NO SAILOR SHOULD HAVE EVEN BEEN
LIVING ON THAT SHIP IN THOSE
CONDITIONS.
>> Reporter: THE MASTER CHIEF
PETTY OFFICER OF THE NAVY, THE
BRANCH'S TOP ENLISTED SAILOR,
CAME HERE A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
TO SPEAK WITH THE SAILORS ON
BOARD.
THE MESSAGE HE LATER SAID IN A
STATEMENT WAS TO HEAR THE
DIFFICULTIES AND THE CHALLENGES
THOSE SAILORS FACE.
BUT SAILORS WHO WERE THERE THAT
SPOKE WITH CNN SAY THE
UNDERLYING MESSAGE WAS, GET USED
TO IT, IT COULD BE WORSE.
ONE SAILOR CALLED THE VISIT
LAUGHABLE AND OFFENSIVE.
THE NAVY SENT MORE MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES TO THE TEAM AFTER THE
LATEST SUICIDE.
AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
SUICIDES IS EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED THIS WEEK.
ANOTHER INVESTIGATION INTO THE
COMMAND, CLIMATE, AND CULTURE
WILL TAKE MORE TIME.
THE COMMANDER OF U.S. NAVAL
FORCES ATLANTIC SAYS THEY'LL
LOOK AT THE QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUES.
THE NAVY BEGAN MOVING HALF OF
THOSE SAILORS TO DIFFERENT
ACCOMMODATIONS.
PROMISING THAT THOSE WHO WANT
ANOTHER PLACE TO LIVE WILL GET
IT.
A FORMER GEORGE WASHINGTON
SAILOR WHO LEFT THE NAVY AFTER
HIS TIME ON THE SHIP CALLED IT
WILLFUL NEGLECT.
>> THAT'S SOMETHING
UNACCEPTABLE, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE BUDGET OUR MILITARY HAS, AND
THE SUPPORT IT'S SUPPOSED TO
HAVE BEHIND IT.
I MEAN, THIS ISN'T AFGHANISTAN
WHERE YOU'RE EXPECTING THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS IS NEWPORT NEWS, VIRGINIA.
>> Reporter: THE REFUELING
PROCESS AND THE OVERALL PROCESS
THAT THE SHIP IS GOING THROUGH
NOW WAS SUPPOSED TO TAKE FOUR
YEARS.
AS OF RIGHT NOW, IT WILL GO
UNTIL AT LEAST MARCH OF NEXT
YEAR, MEANING SIX YEARS.
AND THAT, SAILORS SAY IS PART OF
WHAT HAS LED TO THESE PROBLEMS,
THESE DELAYS.
JAKE, THE REASON THEY DECIDED TO
COME OUT AND TALK TO US IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT ANY
OTHER CREW TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THESE SAME PROBLEMS.
BUT THEY FEAR WITH ANOTHER SHIP
ALREADY BEHIND THE GEORGE
WASHINGTON IN THE SHIPYARD,
OTHER CREWS MAY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THESE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY HAVE FACED NOW FOR NOT ONLY
MONTHS BUT YEARS.
>> OREN LIEBERMAN, THANKS SO
MUCH.
WE'RE JOINED NOW BY NAVY VETERAN
AND CONGRESSWOMAN ELAINE
LAUREATE, TWO SERVES ON THE
HOMELAND SECURITY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEES.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
YOUR REACTION TO WHAT WE LEARNED
FROM THAT ROSHT, ESPECIALLY THE
DESCRIPTIONS OF THE SAILORS
SLEEPING IN HIS CAR, ANOTHER
DESCRIBING WILLFUL NEGLECT?
>> I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VISITING THE "GEORGE WASHINGTON"
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
ANY DEATH IS A TRAGEDY, AND THE
FACT THAT THERE WAS A STRING OF
THREE OF THESE IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY, ONE HAS TO STOP AND
SAY THERE NEEDS TO BE A DEEP
LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING AT
THIS COMMAND AND OTHER COMMANDS.
I STARTED BY WRITING A LETTER TO
THE CHIEF OF NAVAL OPERATIONS
ASKING TOUGH QUESTIONS.
WHAT INVESTIGATION ARE YOU
DOING, WHEN CAN WE EXPECT THE
RESULTS, TELL US ABOUT THESE
THINGS.
WE HEAR PHONE CALLS FROM THESE
SAILORS WHO NEED ANSWERS TO
THESE QUESTIONS.
I REQUESTED TO GO TO THE SHIP
AND TALK TO SAILORS AND SEE THE
LIVING CONDITIONS.
I WAS THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER ON A
SHIP MYSELF.
THE XO WALKS THROUGH THE
BERTHING COMPARTMENTS, THE MESS
DECKS, TALKING TO SAILORS.
I WANTED TO HAVE A TIME ON THE
SHIP AND HEAR FROM THE CREW.
>> AND WHAT DID THEY TELL YOU?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE SHIP
ENVIRONMENT IS INCREDIBLY TOUGH.
I TALKED TO A LOT OF JUNIOR
SAILORS.
THIS IS THEIR FIRST COMMAND, THE
FIRST PLACE THEY'VE BEEN IN THE
NAVY, THE ONLY THING THEY KNOW
ABOUT THE NAVY.
AND THEY'RE TRAINED FOR SPECIFIC
SKILLS WHEN THEY GO THROUGH BOOT
CAMP AND SIGN THE LINE TO ENLIST
AND COME IN.
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THEY HAVE TO
SPEND SOME TIME IN THE SHIPYARD.
THE SHIP REQUIRES REPAIR AND
OVERHAUL, BUT SHOULD WE BE
SENDING THEM RIGHT TO THAT
ENVIRONMENT?
THESE ARE LENGTHY OVERHAULS.
IT'S A REFUELING OF THE CARRIER
AT THE 25 YEAR POINT TO GET
ANOTHER 25 YEARS.
BUT THIS IS AN ISOLATED PLACE
FOR SAILORS WHO DON'T HAVE CARS,
THE ONLY PLACE THEY HAVE TO LIVE
IS ON THE SHIP.
THEY'RE VERY ISOLATED AND THEN
PUT COVID ON TOP OF THAT, AND
THEN THE CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS OF AN
INDUSTRIAL ENVIRONMENT TO LIVE
IN.
SO I TALKED WITH THE SAILORS AND
TALKED TO LEADERSHIP.
ONE OF THE THINGS I TOOK AWAY IS
BECAUSE THIS AVAILABILITY OF
THIS MAINTENANCE PERIOD JUST GOT
EXTENDED ANOTHER 19 MONTHS, A
DECISION HAD BEEN MADE SEVERAL
MONTHS BACK TO MOVE THE CREW
BACK ON BOARD.
THE LEADERSHIP CLEARLY SAID,
HAVE WE KNOWN THAT IT WAS GOING
TO HAVE THIS EXTENSION OF
ANOTHER 19 MONTHS, IN HINDSIGHT,
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD HAVE MADE
THAT DECISION AT THE TIME.
SO I THINK THAT THESE ARE
STRESSFUL SITUATIONS, AND MANY
THINGS CAN ADD UP.
THERE ARE THESE FRICTION POINTS
FOR SAILORS.
LONG WORKING HOURS, WORKING
SHIFT WORK, BEING AWAY FROM HOME
FOR THE FIRST TIME INNEN
INDUSTRIAL ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN THE SITUATION OF THE
SHIPYARD.
SOME SAILORS WHO LIVE OFF THE
SHIP, IT TAKES THEM TWO HOURS TO
GET TWO AND FROM WORK IN EACH
DIRECTION.
SO THERE'S THINGS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT.
I WENT THERE AS A FORMER OFFICER
WHO SERVED ON SIX DIFFERENT
SHIPS BUT DEPLOYED THREE TIMES
ON CARRIERS, KNOWING WHAT THE
EXPECTATION WAS AND WHAT I WOULD
SEE OR WHAT I SHOULD SEE, AND
THESE QUESTIONS OF LIKE WHY --
WE HAVE EIGHT MORE CARRIERS TO
REFUEL.
IT'S ANOTHER 40, 50 YEARS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SHIP AT THAT
PIER BEING REFUELED.
WE SHOULD BE MAKING INVESTMENTS
AND MAKING SURE THAT SAILORS
HAVE A QUALITY OF LIFE THAT CAN
BE HEALTHY FOR THEM AND MAKE
THEM MORE PRODUCTIVE SAILORS AND
HAVE A POSITIVE EXPERIENCE.
NOW AS A MEMBER OF CONGRESS, I
WANT TO ASK THE QUESTION, WHAT
INVESTMENTS DO WE NEED TO BE
MAKING TO MAKE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE BETTER?
>> SO LAST WEEK, YOU WROTE A
LETTER TO THE CHIEF OF NAVAL
OPERATIONS DEMANDING IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
THIS CREW.
HAVE YOU GOTTEN A RESPONSE?
>> I AM WAITING FOR A WRITTEN
RESPONSE, BUT I HAVE CERTAINLY
GOTTEN A RESPONSE FROM THE CNO
STAFF, SEVERAL OF THEM
ACCOMPANIED BEALONG WITH THE
FOUR-STAR COMMANDER TO VISIT THE
SHIP.
BUT THEN I BROKE OFF SEPARATELY,
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
SAILORS.
I KNOW THAT A MORE THOROUGH
RESPONSE WITH THE INVESTIGATION
MENTIONED WILL BE FORTHCOMING.
>> THIS IS A NEVER ENDING SERIES
OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT SERVICES
NEEDING TO IMPROVE FOR VETERANS
IS.
THAT IS IS TRUE.
THIS IS DEFINITELY A CHALLENGE
AND ONE THAT I TAKE SERIOUSLY ON
MY ROLE ON THOSE COMMITTEES.
WE DO HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES, THE HEALTH CARE THAT
THESE VETERANS AND ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS DESERVE.
THEY SIGNED THE LINE, THEY
RISKED THEIR LIVES IN THE
DEFENSE OF OUR COUNTRY AND IT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO ASK
THESE TOUGH QUESTIONS AND WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO MAKE THE
SITUATION FOR THE CREW OF TH